good morning believe nation today's
message is find your inspiration over to
you Enzo Ferrari sua philosophy uh did
he say no the less we mocking it here I
puke in official Oh Mia yummy so no
report Otto Allah premium precio Nikkei
bean and Milanovich a tradition of a
universal Americana
que Viva cosas Indianapolis a Kerala
Picard which is even that well momento
aa Sposato in moto really teach it in
three you know no beauty world theater
so what do you think I think that often
we go through life daily seeing things
that could be our inspiration but if
you're not open to it if you're not
aware of it if he wasn't at the track
and using someone else's work as
inspiration for himself he would have
passed right by that moment and never
realized it so I think with finding your
inspiration the key is being open to
what's around you and recognizing when
you get that inspiring when you get that
excitement what do you do with that do
you write it down where you go with it
how do you use it how do you implement
it how do you not let it just pass you
by yeah from for me I think my
inspiration was when I was first invited
to go speak at the YMCA to a group of
entrepreneurs and I was so excited to go
and share my knowledge I just sold my
business and I was excited to go help
other entrepreneurs and I promoted it
and they promoted it was a free event
and only three people showed up to this
thing which is super heartbreaking after
all the work that I put into making it
happen
but it was just such an amazing session
and I felt like even if I had no idea
how to make money off of this you look
at that idea on paper and you think
that's stupid it's never gonna make
money you can't get people to come to a
free event how would they ever pay you
how are you gonna turn us into a
business even if I couldn't make money
off of this I had to find a way to keep
going because I loved it so much I
it fuels me I can I breathe
entrepreneurship I eat it I sleep it
it's always a part of me and that moment
was when I realized that this is
something I really want to do and I
think if you can find that moment in
your life something that makes you come
alive then even if doesn't make sense of
how you're gonna turn into a business
you have to go for it because you'll
figure it out along the way as long as
you take action oh but look at how those
three people that attended your event
all those years ago have now turned into
so many people we're watching this who
are liking this love you guys
so the question of the day today is I
would like to know in your business and
in your personal life the one thing that
inspires you I like it leave in the
comments below we're gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
good so what do you think now evan is
crazy
good morning believe nation today's
message is know your inspiration find
your inspiration know your inspiration
find your inspiration find your
inspiration alright